so a lot is being written and said about
deep learning in the new AI wife and not
everything is true so here's one of the
things that's not true so the idea that
machines program themselves these days
and all you have to do is put mediocre
data in turn the crank and outcome
excellent results but there is what I
think of true magic in this deep
learning and here's what really
fascinates me the most about this field
is deep learning lets us solve problems
we don't know how to program so we can
solve problems we actually don't
understand in detail so in insufficient
detail that we can program a solution
the first time I witnessed this is quite
a while ago it was around 1992 I was in
at ETH in Switzerland working on reading
machine for the blind and we made good
progress on printed text but we when we
got nowhere for handwritten text and so
I was reading through paper after paper
with promising titles and just to be
disappointed time and again so most
people back to in there worked on
capital letters from A to F for example
did tiny variations to the bitmap and
then called it font invariant and then
somebody pointed me to the work of young
laocoon and I looked into that and was
very fascinated because he was working
with actual data from the US Postal
Service
no cheating possible and he claimed to
have excellent results and his methods
were comparatively simple so we rushed
to implement this and well first we had
to rush to actually collect data and
then train the network and it felt like
magic it was actually read and do this
seemingly impossible task so a year
later I was fortunate to join that very
team at Bell Labs so I divided my
presentation into two parts the first
part they will talk about the early deep
learning work at Bell Labs and then the
second part I will talk about our
current work at Nvidia on self-driving
cars so from 1990 from 1985 to 90 1995
was a ten-year period it was incredibly
productive so in that team that team not
only created convolutional networks it
also created support vector machines as
VMS and laid a foundation of important
machine learning learning theory and
also created several generations of
neural network chips this is the
building in Holmdel New Jersey so
gigantic building actually at eighth
house about six thousand employees 300
of those were in research and 30 of
those were in machine learning so you
probably recognize several of the names
and since as researchers we tended to
show up late in the day we always have
to park way out here which added about
10 more minutes to your commute just to
walk into the building in into your
office there's these two ponds here
could you imagine what they are for
they're not just landscaping yeah yeah
disorder heat exchanger for the for the
air conditioning of the building or used
to be
later they replaced and with cooling
towers this is the very first data set
that I worked with collected among the
researchers themselves light that I got
data from the US Postal Service and then
that grew into NIST and then list which
is still very widely used today so a lot
of the work was about what structure
will be put into the learning machines
what prior knowledge do we equip them
with to to perform the task well if you
talk about a field if you look at this
example here
and you needed to build a classifier
that can distinguish between the red and
the green classes and you wonder what
class cuz this X belong to so if you
take location east west north south as
your criteria to classify then you would
probably say the X belongs to green but
if you understand that these points are
actually real points on the surface of
the earth and it happens that the green
ones are on border and the red ones are
on land and you could change your
criteria and say we take level above the
height above sea level as criteria in
which case the problem becomes trivial
so this point is actually on land so it
belongs to the red class anybody see
where that vertices this is Manhattan
New York so this is an example how
programming or using prior knowledge
actually helps classification tasks
enormous Lee of course that led to the
creation of convolutional networks this
is an old slide that we use to explain
how they work naturally you have these
convolutions that can learn to do detect
lines vertical horizontal and then next
layer can detect edges and so on and of
course the leap of faith was that we
don't have designed these features but
actually let a numerical optimization
algorithm find optimal solutions here's
an old video from Yonder kuhn showing
Lynette this was on an old AT&T PC I
believe was a DSP accelerator in it
so meeow meeow may have seen the video
it's it's a new tube
and at that time many many many
brilliant minds tried so hard for years
to solve the problem and here comes this
network and just does it was almost
looks with ease then Jung gets creative
I'm quite sure that this type of
characters were not in the training set
some other people from the lab this is
Tony Henderson and rich Howard who was
the lab director at the time so as we
became to look at learning is
essentially two main things one is to
build prior knowledge into the
architecture or what vladimir vapnik
calls structural risk minimization and
the other one is capacity control so you
need to match the size of your network
to the amount and diversity of the data
that you have and one really good tool
to do that or to to analyze that is
learning curves so this is not the
number of epochs here it is actually
each point on this chart is a fully
trained Network so what you do is you
measure the performance of your network
on the training set and on the test set
while you're growing in the amount of
data that you're training the network
with so this is the the number of
examples that you use for training so if
you have very very few examples then the
network can essentially memorized
training set and DDT error on the
training site is zero
while the error of the test set is very
big and then as you grow the data set
the error on the test set comes down and
at some point the network can no longer
memorize and the entire data set and the
training set error starts to grow and
empirically it's been shown that these
curves eventually they meet and you
don't need to plot the entire curve it's
usually in the middle between the two
curve so you can have a good idea what
to expect so if you hit this point here
then it becomes clear that it doesn't
help you to add more data you have to
increase the capacity of your network
here's learning her from real life that
we did last week so this is here
predicting the steering angle of a human
so how close does the network steer
likely human and you see that around
here we reached a point where adding new
data wouldn't help us then in the 90s
there was sometimes heated debate about
what is the best algorithm for
classifying characters and the the
[Music]
manager of the group at the time was
larry jackel and he said well let's just
find out and compare all of those so
this was one of these ideal situations
where you had several people competing
with ideas and everybody was convinced
my idea is the best so we compared them
all and if I remember correctly that's
what that's the reason that I created
the amnesty database for so M stands for
modified the result is somewhat
interesting so K nearest neighbor that
nobody believed that that would be the
winner that was just there for reference
also fully connected Network which is
there for reference then this is Lynette
one this was optimized for a much
smaller data set from the United States
Postal Service so that didn't do very
well on this either in fact it was even
slightly worse than fully connected and
then this year these were the actual
competitors so this is convolutional at
lock but this time optimized for the
larger and this data set I'll get back
to boosting in a minute then different
variations so here for example K nearest
neighbor of course has one big flaw so
if you just take the Euclidean distance
as your metric as we did here then if
you shift two characters which are
active
the same by a few pixels then the
Euclidean distance starts to become
enormous so it doesn't really measure
how close to or how similar two
characters are very well so here the
idea was that let's instead of using the
Euclidean distance let's do the same
thing and used to Euclidean distance but
not on the pixel space but in the
uppermost feature map and that boosted
the performance quite a bit
tangent distance was another one of the
ideas we talked a lot at a time another
clever trick to increase the performance
of K nearest neighbors so if you picture
each character to be a point in a very
high dimensional pixel space and you
start doing some perturbations to it
without changing the actual character so
you rotate you delete a little bit is
shifted you grow the stroke a bit then
that forms a surface around that point
and if you don't deviate too much from
the original point and you can model
that as a plane and the tangent distance
is simply the Euclidean distance between
two such planes so clever idea was a lot
of prior knowledge of the problem built
into and that also gets very good
performance and optical margin that's
essentially an SVM and so what's
interesting is that they all have the
exact same performance the only one that
actually improves the performance was
boosting which is kind of a different
type of approach so here you train
multiple networks you train the second
network on the mistakes of the first one
and you train a third one on there
refers to disagree so you get multiple
expert that specialize on different
parts of it of the training sentence so
it's not too surprising that that
actually would increase the performance
so what Larry said in hindsight is that
well it's not too surprising that they
would all perform the same because they
everybody was doing the same type of
approach in exploring them the best
capacity of their learning system by
doing the learning curves the one thing
that stands out in my mind is the SVM
because that has no bit prior built-in
knowledge about the tower
at all there all of the others to
classification rate is not the only
thing that you should actually focus on
of course it's also memory consumption
which is not on this chart training time
and inference time so all of the memory
based K nearest neighbor types they use
very little training time but then they
use a lot of memory so the lessons some
of the lessons that I took from that
time is one is still very relevant is
look at the data I've seen so many
people miss important cues confused why
you II was RGB for example that doesn't
make your system fail completely it just
doesn't perform as well as he could
solely debugging tools are critical
these neural networks have a nasty habit
of masking box and they learn to adapt
today they tried their best to work
around box validator training data again
thats related to look at the data so
many data sets i've seen actually have
grave labeling mistakes and the work is
experimental in nature at least that's
what it is the state of today so in most
cases you can't just copy paste or
recipe from somebody else that will now
give you the optimal results and the
last one is work was real data synthetic
data is great for debugging and you can
certainly explore certain trends but to
get a sense of where you really are you
you have to work with real data so what
happened after 95 actually right around
the 95 AT&T released first production
version of convolutional networks for
commercial check reading and eventually
20% of all the checks written in the US
were processed by that system or read by
that system to me that was the real the
real sign of success if technology is
commercially viable
at the same in the same year actually we
were in the morning sitting together
discussing how we should celebrate this
fact this success was the commercial
check reading and message came in that
AT&T ET announcement came in that AT&T
would break up into three parts so that
was quite a shock and then in 2002 there
were mass layoffs and most people left
and some of the important folks from
machine learning day found themselves
working together again either at DARPA
or for DARPA and created several
programs such as locker learning applied
to ground robots learning locomotion one
was even called deep learning and also
they're helping to get the various
different DARPA challenge is launched
and then in 2002 deep learning becomes
really popular and I guess it's
triggered by the availability of data
the availability of compute power and
also ready commercial applications so
this large scale internet applications
in speech recognition in image
classification they were ready at East
Point and I guess there was just not too
much money in check reading for the
economy to take notice back then so this
brings me to what we're doing today
very similar technology applied to
self-driving cars in this case so first
an overview of the entire stack offer
and be yourself driving so we have at
the bottom the outer that goes into the
car that's the Drive px family of
products the most recent is called
Pegasus that was just announced at CES
then we have the operating system a
real-time operating system layer and
then the top of that is dry folks that's
what I call the middle layer so that
does sensor abstraction does all the
logging tools inter process
communication and it has low-level
computer vision libraries such as image
transformations
and on top of that is drive a B this is
the application layer so this is where
we put together all of the other
technology to form actual applications
and some examples are here this is
Center fusion from radar and camera on
this is light our point cloud processing
or deep learning based object detector
so they detect the bus here or the
pedestrians back there this is deep
learning based free free space detection
this is localization based on HD maps
and then this here is perception based
as planning this is actually what comes
out of our group in New Jersey so what
New Jersey group is doing there we
contribute into this layer here and our
goal is to solve the heart and unsolved
problems and I think there's a lot of
those in self-driving car so I think
back to character recognition if we
can't even program handwritten character
recognition then it's very likely that
dealing with other humans and all kinds
of different situations is likely not
going to be solvable by just programming
so we concentrate on these hard problems
for two reasons one is that we want to
provide algorithmic diversity so in a
safety critical system it's unlikely
that you want to rely on any single
algorithm and the second reason is that
we can solve functionality that might
not be solvable otherwise like taking
terms just based on perception without
map data or learn too much onto a busy
highway where you have to negotiate with
the other cars and squeeze yourself in
and then other the other labs the other
autonomous labs in Nvidia are in
California in Boulder in Seattle and in
Europe
this is uh they're actually back in the
same building which is cool the building
was empty for over ten years but it's
now being redeveloped for mixed-use so
there's a number of different tech
companies in there so Nvidia is renting
space around here and there's also
they're going to get restaurants and
shops and on the rooftop there's plans
to build a hotel the reason why there is
not so much sentimental it's because
this is actually a very good environment
for testing self-driving cars we have
plenty of space in the basement of the
building to store and work on the cars
and then there's two tunnels here and
with that we can take and their leaders
right up to these private routes here on
the campus driving months around here is
actually two miles and then right
outside we have a very nice mix of
Highway local roads and residential
roads the location is also quite nice so
we're about 45 miles from New York City
and there's train connection and ferry
so a train is about 60 to 70 minutes and
if areas faster actually can take the
shortcut so it's around 40 minutes so
what is the typical case where rule
based systems struggle well this seems
clear so we can detect these lane
markings localize the car within it and
then have a pass planner and the
controller and drive but just about 100
meters further up on this road the
situation looks like this so it's much
harder now so it is you have to double
yellow line marker paint it and then the
center one is almost gone
you can still solve it of course you can
build a deck too for this curve what a
fence you may be able to reconstruct
this yellow lane marking then you can
measure the distance here and decide
that this is actually wider than on line
this is probably two lines and I'm
currently here so I'm going to assume
that there's a virtual Lane here and I'm
going to drive there and then you have
solved the problem for tests for this
scenario and then around the corner it's
different again
so you have to start all over and then
again and again so it seems a big
advantage if we can build a system that
can derive the domain knowledge from
data so by just observing humans not by
somebody telling it what it actually
should look for in this scene so what we
this is one of the things that we built
if this is the lane here that's where
the car currently is then we predict
there with the human drive so what is
the short-term trajectory that the human
who take given that image and so
collecting the data is relatively simple
you just drive you can then derive this
trajectory from the emotion of the car
so the training labels you essentially
collect them for free without additional
manual labor while you're collecting the
data and so then the difference between
what a human drove and what the network
predicts that's the error signal that we
back propagate this is an example
network architecture this is from about
two years ago it still looks similar but
it's growing so we constantly adapted to
the current size of the training set the
universal sign for photo
these are all rows and with this
approach it really doesn't matter
whether the road looks horrible grass
overgrown or is a nice highway as long
as the estate that I can run from it
[Music]
since these roads are currently not used
anymore on our campus so let's just
ideal for for experimental knowledge
[Music]
well cool
so the noises in the background they're
not they're not acting this is actually
real we struggled so so much to get this
to work for a for an important they were
deadlines and was just about 12 hours
before the drop-dead deadline that this
thing started working there was a big
relief so this is a made-up construction
site with some unpaved section in the
back people often asked well if you
train this in California can you drive
in New Jersey so we showed it here we
trained with California data only an
hour driving gear on a New Jersey
Highway and here at night it was
drizzling slightly on an unpaved road in
a nearby park
[Music]
got it so we'll move on to something a
little more practical this is highway
driving so here we're driving you'll see
our here you see this is what the
network predicts what the human would
drive and you see that line markings
here are lousy and in in part they're
completely missing and that doesn't seem
to impress the network it protects
co-products predicts the correct
trajectory what you see here is we we
show the trajectories predicted from the
most recent 10 frames and then correct
them for eager motion of the car and any
show them all on top of each other this
is a debugging tool if the network is
confident it will be consistent with its
predictions over a few frames and the
noodles are nice and tight and if it's
not confidence then they'll spread out
all over the place it will predict
something different each frame so here
not to drive taking tected exit or here
again this is all stuff that we haven't
programmed it just picked it up by
observing humans we're not limited to
two on line keeping we can also learn on
line changes so this is a video showing
that the the line changes are triggered
manually by this is chained each end
here driving and he's he's just tipping
the lever for turn signal and thats that
indicates the car it should now change
lanes we can also learn different
lengths of the line changes so we can
tell the car to complete the lane change
in 200 meters or 100 meters or 50 meters
that's actually quite exciting at
highway speed completing a lane change
in 50 meters we can also allow them to
take
[Music]
this was particularly exciting because
I'm not sure there's really any other
way to do this
[Music]
so one of our internal goals is to be
able to send the car on its own to get
ice cream this is the route from the
active
what some people is to get back
you see that half the Veneto finish here
[Music]
[Applause]
yes the entrance
so one of the things I mentioned before
that it's important that or an important
aspect of our work is to learn by
observing humans not by manually
programming things into the system but
nevertheless we want to understand what
it actually learned so here we analyzed
what what it's looking at is these two
green regions these are the regions that
the network is sensitive to and you see
that it learns to recognize detect these
line markings which is interesting
because we never labeled a single line
marking during training or here in a
residential street it learns to look at
the cars but if you look closely it
ignores the trees here or on our campus
if there's no clear line markings it
learns to figure out to detect a road
edges through other means so this is an
important very important debugging tool
for us here's a short video you see a
line much so while the driving on the
highway it's looking at both line
markings but this one will disappear in
a moment and now instead of looking at
both of a doubly wide lane is actually
just following this one until the right
one comes close enough so it becomes a
single line again and it picked that up
by observing this is not as manually
programming that into the system at one
point some day we needed a screenshot
from the inside of the car and there's a
lot of construction going on on the
campus currently and this Bobcat comes
out into our roadway and if you look
here the network prominently recognizes
it even though we're quite certain it's
never seen this type of vehicle in the
training before so I wanted to close
with some open challenges my mind T's
are well they have tons of open
challenges but these are two of the big
ones
one is to deal with ambiguous situations
so if you imagine you want to learn to
merge onto a highway and you have a car
right next to you then you can either
speed up and go in front or you can slow
down and go behind but you can do the
average
so how we how we deal with that how we
can learn from there as more than one
possible correct way of driving but you
only ever get one one one of these
possible options in each example and
then the other one is learned from
imperfect behavior so we have a ton and
ton of data but currently we need to cut
out all the imperfect driving you don't
want to teach the network to cutting
corners and such and and it does learn
what you what you do so it may make
Stevens so if we can get around and
figure out how I can learn on its own
what it actually should look at and
bodies for their outliers then we would
have a ton more data that we can work
with and so I'll finish with this video
here this was recorded recently in
December we got new data from a new
sensor set of a new car fleet and so the
first 10 hours came in all California
data in the Sun very little night no
rain and so the first thing we usually
do is we train a network we go out and
test to see if it meets our expectation
is this kind of an end-to-end test to
see to make sure that nothing's wrong
with this new data that day it happened
to snow so we were curious to see what
happens and it actually performed
surprisingly well so all these network
has ever seen is California data and
it's now driving in the snow in New
Jersey or here at night on a partly
snow-covered Road with lights from
oncoming traffic you can also see what
it's looking at and it looks at what
seems correct features on the road here
it even looks at the threaded tire tread
markings in this now even though it
certainly hasn't seen that in in the
original training data and that brings
me to the end thank you for your
attention
[Applause]